l'assemblée nationale je vous rappelle
adopté hier la loi 2 qui va faire passer
l'âge légal de la consommation de
cannabis
à 21 ans au québec l'âge légal de
consommation de marque 18 ans partout
ailleurs au canada
quoique certaines provinces sont à 19
ans met donc au québec ce sera 21 on n'a
pas la veille jean sébastien a fallu
professeur en psychoéducation une
version montréal s'est fallu bonjour
bonjour comment vous réagissez à cette
décision de québec
ben grande déception ça part d'une bonne
intention protéger les jeunes mais
malheureusement on n'arrivera pas à
protéger les jeunes eux mêmes on va
empirer la situation pour les jeunes en
les obligeant s'approvisionner aux mains
du marché noir marché légal ne produit
pas du tout contrôler de taux de thc
prend très variable et les maîtres au
sens en porte à faux avec les règlements
la police revoit les pourchasser ça va
ça va créer beaucoup plus de problèmes
que et des munitions part d'une bonne
intention mais pourtant dans la dernière
année en plus un drapeau qui ont été
levées de la part de la santé publique
des médecins également qui dit au
gouvernement que c'est peut-être pas la
façon de faire comment vous expliquer
cette décision
effectivement je connais personne
personnes spécialistes en santé publique
est d'accord avec ça évidemment il ya
des psychiatres qui soutiennent le
gouvernement
l'association des psychiatres parce que
c'est pas tous les psychiatres est
d'accord parce que des risques pour la
santé mentale
par contre des pédiatres de
l'adolescence qui sont unanimement
contre pourquoi le gouvernement va de
l'avant mais parce que c'est une mesure
populaire je dirais même populiste
c'était une promesse électorale
il y en a qui ont été abandonnés bref
c'est sûr que ça elle le grondement
l'appui de la population malheureusement
c'est pas parce que c'est risqué comme
les psychiatres le dise pour la santé
mentale pour la santé que sa commande
nécessairement une interdiction on sait
l'interdiction si on ça marche elle
en soirée les jeunes consommaient vont
continuer à consommer ça se pourrait
qu'à une petite augmentation de la
moyenne d'âge d'initiation d'un mois ou
deux chez les moins vulnérables
mais sinon à 18 ans on n'a plus
d'autorité parentale
on ne la maturité pour prendre des
décisions risquées sur cartes de crédit
acheter une maison se marier acheter de
l'alcool s'enrôler dans l'armée
ecce terra chat erreurs mais pas sur le
cannabis les jeunes vont le faire quand
même
ceci permet quand même vont
s'approvisionner sur le marché noir on
va les perdre en brume exactement puis
vont être moins contact avec l'éducation
- contact avec des produits contrôlés et
vont être beaucoup plus dans des
situations de justement de criminalité
voire d'irrégularités avec la loi et
donc la discrimination et on va à terme
vraiment beaucoup plus nuire à la santé
que les autres pays où l'accès vers
d'autres drogues aussi exactement ya
plein de ferveur pour à peu près sont de
fait peut-être pouces fils approche
précautionneuse dont parle lionel
carmant en disant qu'il y va de façon
imprudente
en prenant cette décision ne fait pas
débat table sur le plan scientifique
sont pas du tout parce que justement ça
va empirer la situation vient même des
gens comme daniel white star que
l'équipe qui est un épicier de reconnu
qui milite pour 16,1 pour du cannabis
pour des raisons de réduction des
méfaits il le message qu'envoie le
gouvernement ce point message de
précaution ce message et cohérent qui
dit aux jeunes mais commencer par
l'alcool
un produit généralement plus dangereux
pauvre jean sébastien fallu merci
beaucoup merci merci